when a movie comes together just right
it's something of a miracle but it feels
as natural and inevitable as the weather
pulsating with the skill and creativity
of artisans in their element pulling off
the impossible in the case of costume
hair and makeup this year brought a
perfect storm of creativity it's our
pleasure to honor the behind-the-scenes
heroics of the people who make it all
look easy for us all and make us all
look good here are the nominees for
achievement in costume design American
hustle costume design by Michael
Wilkinson the grand master custom
designed by William Chang soo King
[Applause]
the Great Gatsby costume designed by
Catherine Martin the Invisible Woman
costume designed by Michael O'Connor 12
years of slave costume design by
Patricia Marx and the Oscar goes to
[Applause]
Catherine Martin the Great Gatsby
[Applause]
is the third Oscar for Catherine Martin
Sheila's six nominations
Catherine took home her first two Oscars
in the costume design and art direction
categories for her work on moolah
[Music]
[Applause]
I do have a few words tucked into my bra
it's a very Australian thing to do it's
where you put your tissues I'll be I'll
be very short is sort of a long list um
of course I'd like to thank the Academy
but mainly I'd like to thank my
incredible team I have a group of ladies
who are sewing for me right now in
Sydney on a show we're making of Baz's
first film a musical they're my golden
girls they've been working with me for
25 years they bring me such incredible
luck they'll all be watching the TV
right now and they know who they are
they are there are two people I have to
thank very very specially Carrie
Thompson and Silvana Ozzie Harris and of
course my incomparable husband Baz
Luhrmann he makes it all possible he
dreams the dream
[Applause]